Marco Contreras has waited 20 years for
this moment
a judge confirming what he knew all
along he is watered released he may
leave the prompted celebrations for the
now 41 year-old who spent half his life
in jail for a crime he didn't commit
convicted of attempted murder on the
word of a witness cleared after law
school students found holes in that case
with a hug from his mother he reflected
on getting through two decades inside I
think it has to do with living the
spiritual life and focus in the passive
things helping others and reaching out
to others they just have to be patient
and wait it is another remarkable
victory for the Innocence Project team
from Loyola Law School just two weeks
ago in the same Los Angeles courtroom
they've secured the release of Andrew
Wilson after he spent 32 years in prison
for a murder he said he didn't commit
and for which a judge ruled he'd been
wrongly convicted
prosecutors were found to have withheld
vital evidence from the jury the
prosecutors in Marco Contreras his case
admitted they got it wrong another man
has since been arrested it takes a very
big person like our district attorney to
say mistakes were made but we'd rather
fix the mistakes than have the
conviction mistaken witness
identification is said to account for
three quarters of all wrongful
convictions how many more then should be
walking free
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles